i'm the guy that continues to break the
law from inside secret service offices
for the next ten months until they find
out about it i take off on a
cross-country crime spree still six
hundred thousand dollars in four months
wake up one morning united states most
wanted and uh that gets your attention
what does it mean to be on the united
states most wanted list is there is
there a particular type of criteria that
you need to meet for that is it is it
like being top ten in the the billboard
charts well i i will say you did not
probably do well in sunday school
so it's you're not a good guy if you've
made the united states most wanted list
you are the uh the bane of society at
that moment in time and and me i mean
for those who don't know the secret
service they called me the original
internet godfather i got that title i
was committed i committed 39 felonies i
was placed on the united states most
wanted list i had an escape from prison
and what the big thing of all that was
is i built and ran the first organized
cyber crime community it was called
shadow crew precursor of today's dark
net and dark net markets
that us most wanted
so shadow crew makes the front cover of
forbes august 2004
headline who's stealing your identity
october 26 2004 united states secret
service they arrested 33 people six
countries six hours
i'm the guy publicly mentioned as
getting away i headed that ring they
picked me up four months later they gave
me a job and i'm the guy that continues
to break the law from inside secret
service offices for the next 10 months
until they find out about it i take off
on a cross-country crime spree still six
hundred thousand dollars in four months
wake up one morning united states most
wanted and uh
that gets your attention um
it's one of those oh [ __ ] moments you
know i was in las vegas the night before
i'd stolen 160 000 out of atms
woke up that next morning and there's my
name on carter's market with us most
wanted beside of it and
i sat there and stared at it for a while
finally i said out loud i was like well
brett you've made the united states most
wanted list what now and i i was like
i'm going to disney world so that's what
idiot did went to disney world lasted
about six weeks secret service they came
and got me arrested me sent me to prison
then i escaped
your question
what's it like to be united states most
wanted
it is one of the scariest things on the
planet you um i was already on the run
but you don't have any friends you're
you're constantly watching your back
every day is the highest high
and the lowest low you make it through a
day without being arrested and you're
like yes i made it and but you're
constantly scared of everything i would
uh
you know i just take these long drives
you couldn't talk to anybody i would
there's you've seen breaking bad right
yes
so there's a scene that last season of
breaking bad where
brian cranston's in a cabin and robert
robert forester's bringing these
supplies and cranston looks at forester
and he's like well you just stay and
talk to me and he pays him like 18 000
to talk to him for an hour and i that's
that is really a very truthful moment
because i used to pay escorts not for
sex
but to just sit there and [ __ ] talk
to me and and that's i mean it's just a
uh
it's a completely different life and
mentality when you've done when you're
on that type of list because you know
your days are numbered and so you try to
make the most of them while you can and
it's just complete despair i mean it's
really something to be there how much
are you the architect of your own
anxiety with this obviously you are
genuinely being chased by law
enforcement but the overthinking the
rumination the perpetuation of fear
all of that must be generated
self-generated almost all the time you
know you hear about people that go on
the run there was that um
famous case was it last year of the guy
whose girlfriend went missing and there
was a bunch of body cam footage right
yeah and you think about that
not not only do people who are on the
run need to do the physical things of
not being seen and using cash which is
not trackable and
not being recognized all that stuff
but they also need to get past the sheer
psychological
trauma and and torment perpetual torment
that presumably they're they're making
happen themselves oh it absolutely is i
mean
you
you're driving down the street and
you you're aware of your environment
like no one else i mean you you're aware
when a cop two blocks away pulls in
behind you you know so you're looking to
get off the side of the road you're
making sure that you're obeying all the
traffic laws in the area you're making
sure that
you're watching everyone and every
everything that goes on in your
environment and you're right it is
it's it's
you torture yourself more than law
enforcement could ever think about
because you're always concerned and
worried about what's going to happen and
you know i was constantly moving i
didn't stay any place unless i was
stealing money which i was
but
after the money was stolen i would
immediately leave that area so you were
constantly on the move you you couldn't
trust anyone you couldn't con you didn't
have friends you didn't have family
you know i deserved it i made no mistake
i deserved that but
it's it's a it's a horrible
you can't even call it life it's a
horrible existence to go through how did
shadow crew begin
so
shadow crew
i guess you have and i said this on a
couple of other shows as well my life of
crime
began when i was 10 years old i'm from
eastern kentucky and you know my mom was
a fraudster
she was very negligent she used to leave
me and my sister home all the time and
the way my my life of crime begins is my
sister walks in one day she's got this
pack of pork chops i'm like where'd you
get that and she's like i stole them and
i'm like well [ __ ] let's start doing
that so we start stealing food
mom finds out about it and she joins us
and starts running us as little
shoplifters and and
i refer to it as that eastern kentucky
mentality but that's the
mentality in the south
is that it's the man's job to provide
so while my sister didn't have to engage
in a lot of the crime as a matter of
fact other than that one shoplifting
experience she doesn't break the law
again
me though i was i was the male and
you're expected
to take part so i grew up
committing these different types of
frauds from stealing coal to drug
trafficking document forgery charity
fraud
burglaries
all these different types of things i
learned how to do as i was growing up
branched off on my own in the mid 90s
faked a car accident
to get the insurance money to get
married got married and
you know i said it before and i'll say
it again i get the worst purse for my
mom and my dad my dad i get this fear of
being abandoned my mom i get the
criminal mindset and um what happens
when you blend those two together oh
it's a nightmare so
when when you but when i those two are
blended with me so with me
i have never been able to show love
in a healthy way in a relationship i
always go overboard and
typically that's me showering money or
items on whoever i love and sometimes
it's paying for sex too
but it's typically my love is worth this
this is what i'm worth is whatever i'm
giving you i've not been able to
only only recently have i've been
starting to learn what a healthy
relationship is so back then it was you
know my value
is in what i can provide my mate
materially and if i don't have the
ability to do that legally i didn't mind
doing it illegally so i was always
engaged in some sort of fraud or crime
to to
satisfy
that other side that fear of the loved
one people that i love leaving me or
abandoning me well i think based on what
i know about your background there was
abandonment from your mother that
anxious attachment style would be
developed from that and also it seems
like love was at least in part made to
be contingent on whether or not you
could offer up something even if that
thing was something that had been stolen
so you have
the anxious attachment coupled with
uh gifts and
um money and items are how you show
dedication loyalty and love it doesn't
surprise me that that's what would i i
mean on top of all of that you must have
a genetic predisposition for this as
well if you have a mother that is a
career criminal
there is something inside of you that
can be switched pretty easily i would
agree that there's there's certainly a
switch there without a doubt it's uh it
has not been an easy path for me to give
up that criminal lifestyle and
learn what it is to be healthy and legal
in today's world um you know back then i
had no compuncture at all about breaking
the law i didn't mind scamming people
that was just what i did
my entry into cyber crime i got married
i'm the guy that again i go overboard in
a relationship so it was i'll do all the
work i'll do all the cooking i'll do all
the cleaning you just worry about going
to school so i'm a bit of a control
freak too
and
i couldn't do it all what gave was the
job i go right back into fraud
and start scamming people on ebay and my
first ebay scam was they had a show on
inside edition talking about beanie
babies
i was watching that they were profiling
peanut the royal blue elephant and i
figured hey what can i do so i ended up
dying i bought a gray beanie baby
elephant bought some blue dye went home
tried to dye the little guy
got him out of the bath looked like he
had the mange but i ripped a lady off
with fifteen hundred dollars i
posted a picture of a real one she
thought i had the real thing she wins a
bid and i scammed her out of fifteen
hundred dollars and that's my first this
was 90
probably 96 97 at this point
so scammed her out of that and that's
the
that's when i start to be involved in
cyber crime i got away with that and
that's the first lesson that i learned
is hey
you delay a victim keep putting them off
they go away and they don't report
anything to law enforcement so that's
the first lesson i learned there
kept going and got better at it got to
where i was
installing selling pirated software and
installing mod chips into first gaming
systems then into cable television boxes
so you could watch all the pay-per-view
and then finally programming satellite
dss cards those 18-inch rca satellite
systems you can pull the car down of it
program it turn on all the channels
started doing that a canadian judge
ruled that canadian citizens could
pirate those signals legally so i
started selling all those cards to
canada
making a lot of money didn't have enough
money to fill all the orders i mean
didn't have enough
you know cards to fill all the orders
and quickly thought to myself well why
fill any of them they're not going to
complain to anyone so i stole even more
money and got worried about how much was
coming in figured the best thing that i
could do was get a fake driver's license
use that to open up a bank account
launder the money through the account
cash out at the atm what sort of money
are we talking about here i was at that
point i was stealing around four
thousand dollars a week so sixteen
thousand dollars a month in 97 96 97
so not bad money back then um and you
know no upfront cost really at all so
started looking around thought i found a
guy
to make me a fake driver's license
sent him 200 in my picture and the dude
rips me off
and
i got mad i got really mad about that
did you notice at this point the fact
that you've been ripped off by somebody
on the internet for
pretending to give you something to use
was there any point at which you thought
wow
i'm doing this
what i thought and this this is i think
this is one of the big differences
between criminals and
legitimate people
i took i got mad about it
but i also took it as the cost of doing
business online sometimes you're going
to lose money to scammers but if you
keep just
that endeavor to persevere you just keep
on going
at the end of the day you're going to be
all right so i kept on going and the
result was
i ended up
building and running two different
websites the first one was counterfeit
library counterfeit library transitioned
over to shadow crew over a few years
there are three sites in general there
are counterfeit library shadow crew and
then carter planet i built and ran both
counterfeit library and shadow crew
dmitry golov a ukrainian national builds
carter planet which is the genesis of
all modern credit card theft as we know
it so before those three sites come into
play
specifically carter counterfeit library
and shadow crew
the only avenue you had to commit online
crime was an irc chat session this
internet relay chat rolling chat board
you had no idea who you were talking to
if you could trust the individual if
they knew what they were talking about
if they had a product or service if they
had it if it worked or
if they were just going to rip you off
because everyone there was a crook
so shadow crew specifically solved that
problem it gave a trust mechanism
that criminals could use i built that it
so you had a large communication channel
where individuals from different time
zones could reference conversations days
weeks months old they could take part
they can learn from those conversations
engage in those conversations
you knew
you could look at someone's screen name
and you knew the skill level of that
person if you could trust that person
learn from them or work with them we had
vouching systems in place escrow systems
in place review systems in place all
with that singular purpose
of establishing trust with one criminal
and another when they didn't know each
other's name or what they looked like
and they would never meet each other
shadow crew goes on and shadow crew that
so that's the trust mechanism but shadow
crew was basically this
communication channel and this
marketplace and ebay of criminal
activity shadow crew makes the front
cover forbes like i mentioned in august
of 04 a few months later the secret
service arrests 33 across six countries
in six hours
that is one hell of an operation for
them to coordinate that it is it is so
what happens is is uh my forum techie
his name is albert gonzalez
we hired him to take care of the forum
the software on the forum and he was
doing his job but he was also selling um
stolen credit card details and he was
engaged in what was called the cbv hack
so
the back of your credit or debit card
there are three data tracks there the
first data track is customer's name
second data track is the card number
forward slash
16-digit algorithm outside of that the
third data track is called
indiscriminate data no one uses it
what's bought and sold is the second
data track now we were doing a lot of
phishing at that point in time we were
getting the card numbers and the pins
but for you to encode that on a
counterfeit card and take it to an atm
and cash it out you've got to have that
complete
track to data
that algorithm
you can't guess that you can't generate
it you have to know it well back then we
found out what the ukrainians found out
through testing
that none of the banks had implemented
the hash for track two so what that
meant was is you could take the card
number put a forward slash and any 16
digits out beside of it it would encode
you could take it to an atm start
withdrawing cash we started to do in
doing that and making a lot of money the
profit on that before we were doing that
we were doing what was called cnp fraud
just ordering items online reselling
them on ebay or amazon something like
that
when we started doing the atm cash outs
for cmp fraud we a good carter would
profit 30 to 40 000 a month
on the atm cash outs with that cvv1 hack
we started profiting 30 to 40 000 a day
and that started to get a lot of law
enforcement attention well my forum
techie albert gonzalez
he started to do this cash out at atms
and the way he got caught he's in new
jersey one day broad daylight he's
wearing a wig he's standing at an atm
for 40 minutes
withdrawing cash he puts one counterfeit
card in after another starts pulling out
20s stuffing them in a backpack behind
them meanwhile just so happens across
the street
two new jersey cops
sitting there watching the guy after 40
minutes one of them looks at the other
and says let me go see what he's doing
and they walk up on the guy and and
albert just falls apart he's wearing a
wig everything else is big disguise he
falls apart he goes to work for the
secret service well no one told us he
had been arrested and uh
that was the downfall of shadow crew he
goes to work for the secret service they
didn't know what was going on really and
they asked him how can we catch these
guys and albert's like well have you
tried a uh a vpn
and they're like what's that albert
explains it to them they set up a vpn
have all the traffic go through that and
that's how shadow crew gets busted
how were you
taking cash out of an atm to make it
usable for anything larger than
shopping and buying tvs and stuff that
is a lot of money laundering so what we
were doing what i did
i didn't do the cb1 cash out at that
point in time i was doing tax return
identity theft so i would get a list of
dead individuals and file tax returns in
their name and i would profit about a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars a
week ten months out of the year so what
you do is is you get your i i got to the
point i could file a tax return or
fraudulent tax return once every six
minutes i did that three to four days a
week
on the off day i would plot a map of
atms then i would travel to these those
atms the next two days cash out put 150
000 in a backpack come back home to
charleston south carolina take my
backpack throw it in the spare bedroom
then one day you wake up and you notice
you've got a spare bedroom full of
backpacks and you're like well [ __ ] i've
got to do something with all that money
so then it's about learning how do you
launder money and you have to have a lot
of cash based businesses so think auto
detail think uh food trucks
uh this is the story of breaking bad
again right this is the story of
breaking bad again this was uh 2000 uh
by this point in time it's 2002
beginning in 2002 is when this was
so
think of that thank you and i had bank
accounts in canada in the united states
in mexico and the caymans throughout
europe and then finally bounced things
enough that it ended up at bank latico
in estonia and the idea was is if you
bounce it long enough hopefully you
could make it look legal and obscure it
so no one finds it at the end of the day
so i was arrested february 8th of 2005
my last seizure notice was january of
2010
is when they ended up getting the last
sector from me when they finally ended
up uh completing the trail that had been
left behind right and i still there's
still some funds over in latico that
hell no one knows the name they're under
neither do i anymore i was gonna say
there must be cash that's out there
that's just sat
not doing anything yeah but over the
years you know it gets lost and
everything else
that's crazy so it seems like you were
incredibly motivated to do these crimes
what what what motivates you to go and
do this because a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars five days a week
you can't spend that amount of money no
no you're talking professional athlete
money there professional athlete money
in 2020
not in 2004.
so
what motivates you to keep on going was
it just a game well i mean it start you
know you start out um
with me the the initial motivation was
that love thing you know how do you how
do you give gifts and crap to people
that you love is the initial motivation
but over time
what you see in those cyber crime
environments
is if you can do something that no one
else can do you know if you can build
ransomware deploy it if you can build
bots deploy those whatever you build
skimmers whatever that is if you can do
something no one else can do you gain
the respect of every single person in
that environment you you reach a god
type status where everyone comes to you
everyone asks you questions
you you make and break people and you
with shadow crew and with counterfeit
library
i ran both of those i was the head of
both of those and if someone wanted to
do business they had to go through me at
one point i was
a part of every single transaction that
took part on those websites everything
went through me um
so you've got ego that plays a huge huge
role in that you know that that respect
and status and people fawning over you
and things like that it gets to the
point where yeah money's not really why
you're doing it you've got money you're
doing it for the status and the ego
drive is what you're doing are you
familiar with wall street bets on reddit
i am okay so i've been following them
for
four years plus right way way way before
the madness of amc and gamestop and
stuff last year
and i remember watching that and i think
the thing that's so fascinating about
that subreddit is
people are prepared to risk real-world
fiat money that has taken
weeks and years to accumulate and
they're prepared to risk it all on live
stream for internet points from
strangers that they're never ever going
to meet absolutely absolutely that seems
like a similar dynamic it is you know
with with reddit and
wall street bets or some of the crypto
subreddits it's really interesting the
type of echo chambers that are built
within those types of environments you
know we as human beings we seek out
people that agree with us and you know
continually kind of pump up our egos and
once we find those environments we don't
we don't want to hear anything that
might conflict with that so we stay in
those areas that's the problem with fake
news and in the united states that's a
problem with the left wing and the right
wing
so
and it's really kind of you know it's
it's
reddit is one of these environments
where you can really see that crystal
clear
and it's no different in cyber crime
environments so you find that echo
chamber where you're told that you are
this you know professional that you're
the head of everything that you that you
are this basic god in the environment
and you tend to stay there you don't
want to leave that because you leave
that environment and you're just a
normal everyday person that no one pays
attention to
so it that helps feed into those crimes
absolutely
what's the relationship when it comes to
cyber crime between ability on the
internet
coding understanding of programming and
social manipulation and real world
exploits like that because as far as i'm
away you were
okay on the internet but quite good in
the real world but when you hear cyber
crime you think about some guy with a
200 iq
right programming all day i would say
you know you're right there's this
perception that cyber criminals are
computer geniuses that they're code
savvy everything else i would say that
there are very few attackers like that
there are some maybe one to two percent
but the 98 and 99 percent they're social
engineers they they or they know how to
manage people very well all right
cyber crime when i was a cyber criminal
i'm not a coder by any stretch of the
imagination
i i break down cyber crime into three
necessities i break it down into
gathering data committing a crime and
then cashing out when i talk about
gathering data i talk about that's the
pii the credentials it's the tools that
are needed things like that then you
gather that stuff go out and commit the
crime and then finally put cash in
pocket
the gathering the data aspect i was
never really great at i am very good
about knowing about what to do with that
data and then laundering the money out
from there i'm i'm exceptional with that
now i'm an exceptional money a person
manager as well or manipulator if you
want to call it that
the thing about cyber crime is you don't
have to
know how to code you don't have to know
how to build a tool or steal data or
anything else you've got a group or a
set
that does that for you and they do it
very well we've seen time and time again
that criminals are very good about using
legal off-the-shelf products and
services and using those for criminal
activities you know vm
department what like
uh vm box the tor browser um
you've got some some of these privacy
browsers that are out now
so they're very good about using those
things and repurposing them for criminal
uses and that's typically what happens
why would you
why go out and build it when you've got
a group of people that are funded with
millions of dollars that have done that
for you if you can just repurpose it for
your activity and that's what happens
more often than not you take cali linux
or whatever the new test pen testing
software is criminals use that all the
time
the software that's i forgot what it's
used for i forgot what the thing is it
does the credential stuffing but again a
legal tool
that's been used or repurposed for
criminal activity
stealing data
what you see about most cyber crime is
without social engineering most cyber
crimes fail there's a there's a reason
that ransomware companies
ransomware attackers
anymore they offer that as a service
they build the ransomware then instead
of worrying about deploying it they find
somebody that can deploy it and then
they take a cut of the profit because
the deployment is the difficult part the
building that's not bad but you have to
be able to trick someone into
getting it on their system and that
takes a social engineer to do that what
do you mean when you say deploy
get it installed
so i'm gonna if it means plugging in a
thumb drive if it means you visiting a
site if it means getting you to click on
a link giving me remote access to
something whatever that is that's what
i'm talking about
you know there are
so social engineering plays a part the
other thing that plays a part
because again
media is very good and then all the
security companies are very good about
trying to paint cyber criminals as
hackers that's not really the case the
case is social engineering the case is
also an environment
where attacks 90 of every single attack
uses a known exploit it's not zero day
attacks it's not unknown vulnerabilities
it's stuff that typically has been
talked about for years that no one's
done anything about that creates that
threat landscape that attackers all the
time ping
for example you take something like
equifax equifax the breach happened
after apache announced that there was an
update for a vulnerability no one knew
about the vulnerability until apache
announced it but criminals really
understood that hey they're probably a
whole lot of companies are probably
going to
lay off on installing the update they're
not going to do it immediately so that
understanding
created the equifax problem all of a
sudden and that tends to be the way it
is across the board
what do you know about what happened
with the solar winds
problem
i know that solar winds let me let me
get a drink here because it takes a
minute
solar winds i've got i've got the class
action lawsuit that's been filed against
them i've spoken to the whistleblower as
well
solarwinds is will be
the largest breach
in history when all everything is said
and done
it was a it was a supply chain attack
the
the way they got in
it there were there were some
sophisticated
techniques that were used but entry to
that falls right in within what i was
saying about that 90 these known
exploits the password for example was
widely available online the password was
solarwinds123
the they had had audits by security
professionals saying hey you've got
these issues those people were either
dismissed or not listened to the they
were warned over and over again that
they had security vulnerabilities they
were never addressed because
they were more interested in selling
product than securing their system so
what happened was is you had
the russian
fan i think was fancy bear that got
access to
the solarwinds
backbone you had them they got access to
it and they were able to get snapshots
of basically every single email of every
client that solarwinds had which was
basically the entire fortune 500.
several u.s agents us government
agencies
read every single email they got to them
got ip got everything else that
that they needed and the damage that was
done from that will last for years
absolutely for years it feels to me like
the
serious damage that was done that that
feels like a more technology heavy
attack than what you were talking about
earlier on it seems like it is the
ransomware the code the ability to shut
that down and remain anonymous also
assisted by being in russia
so and you've got so you've got that and
that's a nation-state attack all right
so that's i think it was
you think that it was mandated or at
least allowed by the state i think it
was allowed absolutely along with not
pedia we know not petty is a
nation-state attack so you take both not
pedia was where the uh the russian sand
worm group
they take over the
basically the quickbooks of the ukraine
by faking a microsoft certificate they
take over its update server then they
they put out an update except it wasn't
an update it was a program that looked
like it was ransomware but it wasn't
ransomware it was a program that was
designed to destroy hard drives and it
uses a variety of known exploits it uses
mimikats to harvest credentials out of
ram it uses eternal blue and eternal
romance which were nsa vulnerabilities
that were patched a year prior it looks
for outward facing smbs which have been
talked about for years and how people
needed to turn off those ports
no one had and it causes 50 billion
dollars worth of damage so
between that and solar solar winds is
much more sophisticated bear absolutely
much more sophisticated than not pedia
much more sophisticated than what you'd
see in any of these other you know cyber
crime environments that go out at all
but even though it's sophisticated and
it is it still uses a variety of known
exploits to
gain that control or that access to that
environment
who in the uh if you were to take all of
the countries in the world when it comes
to cyber crime what would you rank the
leaderboard as in terms of effectiveness
and who would be committing the most uh
russia china north korea
iran
you've got the ukraine you've got brazil
um
then it goes down from there you've got
the united states
the usa not be up there do you think
that those countries are doing i don't
think
so i think honestly i think that the us
doesn't have the testicular fortitude to
do what russia or china or north korea
does i mean we certainly don't assign
blame to those countries when we're
attacked by them and i don't think that
we would do the uh the same types of
things
that is a really good point the fact
that it
it almost feels like
um this is the price that you pay for
having that country on this planet right
right so and and think about it i mean
so so who was the who was the guy john
mccain
john mccain referred to russia at one
point as a gas station over in
asia
you're a patient but uh that's what he
said if you think about it
you're seeing the conflict with ukraine
now you're hearing these tales about
russian planes having gps taped
to the console because it doesn't work
in the plane itself you're hearing all
these stories and you're like you know
it's pretty screwed up over there and
we've we've yet to really
assign blame for any of these attacks
that have went on we let not pedia go we
let solar winds go we did raise some
hell about the colonial pipeline
ransomware attack we raised some hell
about that but still we don't really
like to assign blame and we really don't
like to enact any consequences which
might cause more trouble and because of
that i think that gives kind of a you
know
a free pass to these countries that seek
to attack us you know we're not uh we
don't worry about north korea reaching
out and stealing bitcoin we don't really
do anything about china
stealing all the intellectual property
and these things that they do we just
kind of let it happen and i think
there's something wrong with that
was there anything unique about the
colonial pipeline
hack
now except known exploits i mean they
got the password for the vpn off of
pastebin or something like that
so other than that not really
it is strange to think about the fact
that
when those hacks do come from those
countries
it does seem a little bit just like
that's that's what we expect from them
that's that's that's the way that their
culture
causes people who have access to the
internet to do it i was listening to um
the lazarus heist
which is a podcast series and
in it they're explaining about how these
super super smart kids from north korea
that go and do maths competitions over
in asia
are
basically locked in houses working as
computer hackers they're the only people
that have got access to the internet
the proper full internet and a number of
defectors these young guys mostly guys
some girls that go and do these maths
competitions they've lost i think maybe
three or four
of their
best and brightest right who when they
get released into china and they've got
handlers and they're supposed to go from
place to place and they've managed to
evade somebody at some point and finally
escape the clutches of north korea but
yeah make make no mistake about it
despite the fact that it is
basically a third world country
run by a dictator right
they are still incredibly sophisticated
they're just sophisticated in a very
bureaucratic totalitarian way very you
know when i was when i was a criminal
i'm the guy who brought
ukrainians kind of made that connection
between ukrainians and the united states
as far as cyber crime goes
those ukrainians at that point in time
just at that point
they really had no other way
to make a living to provide or get money
in other than committing crime they all
wanted jobs and they just couldn't get
them as a matter one of the ways that uh
so there's a there's a gentleman a
former fbi guy um ed hiddleston i think
is his name something like that there's
there's a wired article about it but
what he does is he captures they arrest
one of these ukrainian cyber crooks and
the cyber crew tells them hey we just
want to work so they ended up
advertising
for employment on it on monster.com and
all these other employment websites and
you had these ukrainian cyber criminals
that would just apply hoping to get a
job so they they just wanted to work
they weren't really about breaking the
law they just needed money that's
changed these days
these days you see these ukrainians or
these russians that their entire focus
is how can i become a cyber criminal
because of the money that can be stolen
because we're allowed to do it as long
as we don't do it in our own country
let's do this to make money to to have a
career i suppose
yeah that makes a lot of sense if your
domestic country isn't going to
prosecute
criminals that are acting against other
foreign nation states
there's
the us isn't going into russia to try
and take one of its citizens and bring
it away
yeah that's very interesting what's your
thoughts on
the julian assange
debacle the entire arc of that
so i i had the i had the
the the i was able to meet julian
assange virtually during a conference
that uh this has been probably five or
six years ago and he was at the
ecuadorean embassy at that point in time
and
my initial reaction to that gentleman is
he is extremely brilliant he truly is i
mean just hearing him talk and being
able to engage with him
i i've never really met anyone that is
as bright as he is
i think that at some point
mr assange
started out as a journalist but i think
he was so adamant about
exposing the united states and some of
these other countries that he stopped
being a journalist and started to engage
in that activity of getting the
information and that's that's why he's
indicted in the united states so he was
working with bradley manning and he
advised bradley manning about how to get
the information and what to do to get
the information at that point you
stopped being a journalist and you
become a criminal at that point
i think it's unfortunate i think that
assange's heart initially was in the
right place but it got skewed somewhere
along the way
i got to be honest with you these days
i'm the guy who if you've broken the law
you need to have your day in court if
that didn't happen
you'll be able to show that and
hopefully not be convicted but if you
did that
you know what you need to fake you need
to have your day in court and figure out
what's going on
i have a lot more respect for bradley or
chelsea manning
than i do for edward snowden edward
snowden because manning stuck manny
believed in what
she did
so much that she stuck around and faced
the charges she didn't run for it
snowden did not snowden stole the data
then immediately ran to russia where he
could not face prosecution manning stuck
around and faced the music and because
of that i don't agree with what either
one of them did but because of that i
have a lot more respect for manning than
i ever will for edward snowden
that's interesting as somebody that used
to be on the run a lot i know right
kind of hypocritical but
that's still what i believe
was the uh cvv
uh exploit was that the most profitable
uh thing that you run
uh the most profitable for me was the
tax return stuff i never engaged in the
cbb once that's what i mean um but for
the most profitable for me was the tax
return identity theft for the group at
large it was the cbv one stuff because
we were
i mean we had tons of information you
were you were getting uh hundreds of
thousands of debit card
numbers and the pins and then
just to put that on a white plastic card
and take it out to an atm and start
withdrawing cash was very easy and the
profit went i think 60 at that point 60
percent of it went to the ukrainians
that were supplying the data the
cashiers or the money mules in the
united states got to keep 40 of it and
everyone was stealing as much money as
they possibly could where were they
getting the original data from the
ukrainians
from fishing phishing attacks right okay
so they were kind of doing the um
brute force
leg work of acquiring the information
and then yeah so you got to figure these
days people know what a phishing attack
is back then they didn't so you could
send out an email that looked like it
came from the bank saying hey we need
you to reset your security but you need
to answer these questions and you could
ask them 30 different questions and they
would fill out every single field they
would tell the driver's license the date
of birth the mother's maiden name
the social security number all the
account passwords they would give you
every single detail that you wanted at
that point and not question it so we
were able to get all that information
and
it was very profitable and very easy to
do at that point nowadays when you're
fishing you're basically just looking
for credentials that's what you're
looking for what's that mean
just the login and password okay
yes yes yes you can you can't get by
anymore with asking every single detail
of someone's identity you have to ask
very specific things like the social
security number
the login credentials something like
that how much violence was there in this
back then
no violence
but and we started to see violence as
shadow crew was coming to an end
dimitri he went by the screen name of
script he's the guy that started carter
planet that genesis of credit card theft
so what happens is as shadow crew was
coming to an end
dimitri comes in and starts to post
pictures of an individual that he had
kidnapped and had tortured then this
individual had owed him money or stolen
money from him or something like that
and dimitri said hey this is what
happens when you steal money from me
that was the first instance of violence
that we saw in those criminal
communities at that point up until that
point we were just people who stole
money and scammed people
what happens though
is
that's the first instance of violence
but we started to see the profit
potential of allowing drugs in those
environments as well for years we had we
had banned drugs and we started to first
allow marijuana then we allowed ecstasy
and then finally we started to deal in
opiates as well
that brings an entirely different
clientele into that environment so you
start to see gangs start to be involved
you start to see people that if they're
caught they're going to do 20 or 30
years in prison because of the dollar
amount because of the drugs that are
involved and when you're looking at that
much time
you are more likely to commit violence
against an individual so that you're not
arrested so it's so today's environment
by to quote monty python violence is
inherent in the system it's part of it
what happened where you were somehow
stealing money from the secret service
whilst working for them
so
i was arrested february 8th 2005
three weeks before i was supposed to get
married
and they let me sit a week in the county
jail
two agents fly in from from new jersey
they pull me out of the cell and they
tell me they've got my laptop i'm like
yeah they're like you got anything on
your laptop i'm like yeah and they're
like you're gonna be charged for it i'm
like yeah i figured
so then that the next question out of
their mouths is can you do anything for
us and my exact words were you let me
get back with my fiance and i'll do
whatever you want me to
well again i'm the guy my motivation
is to
i buy love
so that's that's my main motivation
nothing else just that
so they let me out
the only thing i've got left is that
fiance i don't want to lose her
so i the day i get out i go back into
committing crime
that same night they
they moved me up from charleston south
carolina to columbia south carolina
and i'm working in office anywhere from
in the secret service offices anywhere
from four to six hours a day
six days a week
they've got me hooked up to a laptop
connected to a plasma monitor on the
wall outside internet line beside of me
they've got a desktop system
outside line as well
two secret service agencies agents in
the room at all times a south carolina
law enforcement officer in the agent in
the room at the same time and that's so
i was supposed to be monitored my
computer had camtasia on it and it had
spectre pro so they could record the
keystrokes and then take screenshots of
the screen every night every few seconds
so the first two weeks
they're very diligent they're asking
questions everything else then after two
weeks they start to get bored what are
they getting you to do here what are you
actually doing for them my job is to
surf the web find targets and start
investigations
so for example there's a netflix show
called web of make believe which is
about daniel rigmaden
he's a guy i taught while i was working
for the secret service i taught him how
to do tax return identity theft and then
i set him up to get arrested so that was
my job is to find targets so that we can
arrest build cases against them put them
in prison daniel rig maiden was one of
these individuals
so that was that's what i did four to
six hours and i was very fast about
doing that i would have multiple screens
open up bounce around between the
screens everything else
two weeks of watching that
they get bored and they start to watch
porn on the side well i'm sitting there
watching them like well [ __ ] no one's
watching me and at the same time all the
data that they're recording every night
on my laptop goes on a dvd on a spindle
they don't catalog it or anything and
i'm sitting there going [ __ ] no one's
going to look at that
so i start breaking the law from inside
secret service offices and i do that for
the next 10 months
until they find out about it
in terms of breaking the law and then
what happens how do they find out i'm
buying stolen credit card details i'm
getting the information to commit tax
return identity theft
anything anything that i need to try to
make money is what i or steal money is
what i'm doing the way they find out
about it a contact of mine his name is
sean mims out of los angeles i taught
him how to do tax return fraud
they were set to arrest him i think it
was like march 17th the operation was
called operation rolling stone
they were set to arrest nine individuals
across the united states they go to
arrest sean
they pick him up
at his apartment his apartment manager
comes out and says hey
don't know what went on but last night
this guy had a u-haul truck and loaded
it up full of stuff and bugged out so
there was no evidence in sean's
apartment whatsoever of anything that he
had been doing
so they come back to me
and they're like hey we need you to take
a polygraph to make sure you didn't tell
this guy anything well i i failed the
polygraph
they revoked the bond i go back to the
county jail
i was only under state charges i hadn't
been federally indicted at that point so
the judge a week later the judge lets me
out because they revoked the bond
improperly and i'm i'm of the opinion
hey
if you're going to [ __ ] me you're going
to have to find me so i take off on a
cross-country crime spree with the idea
that i'm going to bug out to brazil
and
i end up stealing 600 000 in about four
months and that's where i make the
united states most wanted list at that
point
what's it like going to jail
it's it's an experience it's uh
i've referred to it as
i refer to it in a few different ways
one of the ways i've referred to it in
the past is it's a lot like kindergarten
except there's some third and fourth
graders with knives
so
i mean so that that's one that's one way
to look at it the other way to look at
it is it's it's an extremely
frightening environment
county jail is probably the worst
because you're mixed in with inmates who
are only there for a couple of days and
then you're mixed in with inmates who
are going to never get out so the
violence is through the roof in county
jails but county a county jail
educates you on how you need to serve
your time in a real prison so you get to
the real prison and you find out pretty
quickly that
guards are just there to do their job
who runs the prison is the inmate and
you're met at the door
by whatever race you are so i'm a white
guy i was met at the door by the
treasurer of the aryan brotherhood did
you have skin heads as well then
you did there were skin heads there
absolutely you have did you have your
current oh no no no this this is just
because i'm follicly challenged
[Laughter]
now back then i back then i had the main
but i was losing it i was gonna say if
you turned up if you turned up looking
like that they would have thought that
they'd seen another one of the brothers
already i know right so uh nick
sanderford was that guy's name i i he
meets me at the door and he was like how
many more white guys come in i'm like
hell i don't know four or five his next
question was is what are you in here for
an idiot that i'm in that i am i looked
at him i'm like computer crime
well it turns out that you can't say
computer crime back then that didn't
mean credit card theft and skimming and
everything else when you said computer
crime then
it meant child pornography
so
he goes and gets all of his shot callers
they gather around and they're like what
the hell did you say you're in here for
so i'm trying to explain it to them
what saves me is
unless they know for sure that you're a
pedophile
they won't attack you so no one had told
them that i was they were waiting on the
guards to confirm that what took
within that first month wired magazine
hits the compound i'm in it and it's
talking about the hacking the financial
cyber crime everything else and i'm like
hell i'm saved and then it's got one
line in there that says brett johnson
secret service informant and i'm like oh
[ __ ]
so they shut down the compound and
warden calls me and he's like did you
give an interview to wired i'm like yeah
and he's like don't you know they'll
kill you here
and then he asked me he's like do you
feel safe well i just got through doing
eight months of solitary confinement
because of the escape and if you tell
them you're not safe they put you back
into solitary for another eight months
until they transfer you so i'm like oh
yeah completely safe
so they try to they do a locker search
to try to get the magazines out they
can't he tells me if anyone says
anything to come back to him
so i go back to the bunk the next day i
walk into the unit there's the treasurer
of the brotherhood he's got the magazine
on his bunk reading it i'm like oh [ __ ]
so i walked up to him i'm like hey nick
what you doing he's like oh doing some
reading anything interesting it's
getting there i was like well let me
save you the trouble
point at the lied to him and he's like
man i already knew
and i was like are we going to have any
issues
he was and he asked me he's like did you
snitch on on anybody that's here right
now and i'm like no he said until
someone gets here you told on
we don't have a problem but
we need you to do something for us so
the something was
in federal prison everyone works doesn't
matter what job you get you got to get a
job so my job was in education teaching
a literature class
and
taught it every wednesday 6 8 30 p.m
all the aryans signed up for the lit
class few of the guards used to attend
to and what i taught was not literature
what i taught every wednesday 6 8 30 was
fraud help me help you whatever you guys
need to know i got you
so because i did that i was not beaten
and
the other thing i did was is i
somebody called me on my youtube channel
they said you were the liaison between
the pedophiles and the aryans and that
was my job you'd see a you'd see a bunch
of white guys come off a bus
the ones that looked like they were
pedophiles you'd walk up to them and my
job was hey
i don't know what you're in here for i
don't care what you're in here for but
if you're in here for something [ __ ]
up you need to tell me because if you
mess with those guys they're going to
kill you
and usually if they were a pedophile
they'd just look at you and say hey man
i just want to do my time and you'd go
back i'd go back and tell the aryans hey
that guy
don't want to mess with him and they
would leave him alone except for maybe
extorting him but he was not allowed to
like uh work on the
he could not lift weights he could not
watch television i could not i thought
that pedophiles would be kos i thought
that would they would be kill on site so
what happened the reason and and a lot
of times they are beaten before i got
there
at big springs so who ran that compound
was a mexican mexican gang called the
paisas all right the aryans had a
population there but they didn't control
the compound
they were so tired of the pedophiles
that were being sent to big spring the
population of pedophiles was about 20
percent that they paid the pisas to
attack the pedophiles and they had this
bright idea they thought that by beating
up all the pedophiles that the
pedophiles would be transferred out of
big spring that didn't happen what
happened was is
the paisas beat up all the pedophiles
and who got transferred out were the
aryans so the aryans had a very small
population when i got there
and because of that
they were very scared to beat up any
pedophiles so the thing was is we'll
extort them we will not let them watch
television we won't talk to them to them
they're only allowed to talk to their
type
and that was the way the the the
environment was at big spring because
they had tried to attack and kill them
previously and had failed miserably at
that point what happens if
one of the
one of those inmates tells you a lie
depends on who's telling you the lie um
you know if it's a pedophile telling you
the lie and i just spoke about this on a
show that i recorded this morning
we had an inmate his name was wesley
evans and he came in he was a pedophile
but he came in and i had this talk with
him and he told me he's like no i'm not
a pedophile i'm in here for selling
marijuana on ebay and i was like how
much time did you get he's like i got 18
years for selling pot on ebay and i'm
sitting there looking like really and
he's like yeah really so that was a lie
that he told and all the
inmates knew it was a lie because you
had people that were serving time for
selling dope on ebay and they didn't get
anything like that
so everyone didn't believe them what
happens is is because it wasn't
confirmed they didn't beat the guy yet
ultimately
they catch the guy gone from his bunk
they break into his locker get his
appeal paperwork out and then find out
he's a pedophile at that point and then
they planned on literally killing him
but word got to him beforehand and he
was able to check himself in before he
got attacked we'll just check himself in
mean he goes up to the warden's office
or up to a counselor or a guard and he
says hey i'm in fear for my life they
send them to solitary confinement for
eight months until they transfer him out
that's a heavy price to pay that's a
choice between two
pretty terrible options it's a it's a
heavy price to pay but at least you've
got your life at the end of the day
when you were talking about the escape
is that the release from
uh the improper bonds
being taken away when you go i was uh i
was sent to prison but uh there's
nothing romantic about a doll i escaped
from a minimum security prison uh so a
camp is where i escaped from i went to
prison
uh got a job working outside of the
fence and one day i just left escaped
like that i lasted about three weeks u.s
marshals they canvassed a three-state
area finally found find me hold up in a
hotel and arrest me and send me back to
prison i spent eight months in solitary
confinement and they sent me from i was
in kentucky at that point they sent me
from kentucky out to big spring texas
where they know how to build prisons
would it have been an easier prison
journey had you have just stayed in that
minimum security thing i'm going to
guess you would have been would you have
just been held in there how did you not
have contravened the rules i would have
done my time there and served out at
that camp but i've got to tell you i was
very fortunate that uh
looking back because hindsight's 2020.
looking back if i would have stayed in
that camp environment there's not a
doubt in my mind that i would have
gotten out and committed crime again
went right back into cyber crime and
everything else i was very fortunate
that i escaped got sent to a real prison
and then had the opportunity
to think about my life and also to take
this cognitive behavioral therapy course
that was a nine month
course in prison that teaches you that
your thoughts determine your feelings
feelings determine your actions and
that really changed my life along with
the help of my sister my wife and then
finally the fbi how long were you in
prison for then
uh sentenced to seven and a half years i
ended up doing right at seven
okay and then you get out and
what happens are you scared about the
prospect of getting out and being back
in the real world well no i i'm like
everyone else i'm getting out thinking
everything is going to be fine but when
you're released you're released from
prison with the exact same tools you go
in with and while you're hopeful of
doing the right thing you find out
pretty quickly you're not going to get a
job
no one's going to hire you especially if
you're the guy who steals everything so
could not get a job selling cars or
anything else had job offers from
deloitte from no before phishing from a
couple of payment processors
my probation stated that i could not
touch a computer so i couldn't take
those jobs i get to the point where i'm
trying to apply for fast food positions
no that cash register is a computer
can't do it so then it's like what about
you know a waiter's position or
something like that well no that's
credit cards and a computer no
so i couldn't get a job and got to the
point where
i was bumming money from my dad and my
sister i had a roommate that was taking
care of half of the rent i was on food
stamps so i had something to eat and
they tell you when you leave prison hey
get a job get something you care about
and you won't recidivate well i couldn't
get a job and what i had that i cared
about i had a cat
and
i had enough money to feed my cat and
didn't have the money to buy toilet
paper so i went to the store dollar
store bought the cat some food on the
way out they had a kiosk right by the
door had some toilet paper there
and that's the first crime i committed
when i got out
and again i look back now and i
it was all very very fortunate for me
that i did that because about the same
time
my wife now she ends up finding me i
ended up moving in with her finally i
the only job i could get was manual
labor pushing a lawnmower
and
busted my ass doing that and was was
thankful to have it and
the unfortunate thing is the job ended
because when it gets cold the grass
doesn't grow
and uh
i go back into crime
what year is this this was 20 uh i was
released in 2011 this would have been
2012 2013 2013 was when this was um go
back into crime i get it in my head that
you know i've got to show her that i'm
worth it
got to do something and i figured hey if
nothing else i can bring food in the
house
so i get some stolen credit card details
start ordering food
get arrested
go back to prison for 10 months and at
my sentencing for that
the only people at the at my sentencing
was u.s marshals the judge the probation
officer the prosecutor
me and then michelle was there she
stands up and she tells the judge that
i'm a better dad to her kids than their
father is i'm sitting there crying
probation officer stands up and he's
like we think he's a good guy we think
it's a good one-time thing prosecutor
says the same thing
judge gives me a year
[Music]
probation officer stands back up and
he's like your honor if you can give mr
johnson a year and a day
he can get the good time and he can get
back to his family quicker and the judge
amends a sentence what's that mean
that means the judge had sentenced me to
a year i was going to serve 365 days
the probation officer
stood up and said judge if you'll give
him
one year and one day he qualifies for
the good time so he gets two months off
so i get out i serve 10 months instead
of 12
and
that's when i find out for the first
time in my life that
someone wanted me not for what i could
give them but just for me i'd had it
with my sister but i had never had it in
a relationship before
that was one of the big changes for me
right there
i serve my time get out we get married
shortly after i get out
they kill probation so i could touch a
computer
and i can't get a job
because i'm the guy who steals
everything and i know even today i know
what my triggers are back then i i knew
i'd go so far before i committed crime
again so i told told my wife i was like
let me see what i can do
signed up for linkedin reached out to
this fbi agent by the name of keith
mullarsky sent him a message i was like
hey man
you did a great job on all these arrests
nothing but respect for you by the way
i'd like to be legal and the guy he
responded within two hours
took me under his wing gave me
references advice and that's where it
starts as he it starts with him
from there the cmp group hires me to be
a keynote speaker microsoft hears about
it
hires me to be a consultant and today i
you know i've got the show behind me i'm
in talks to do the television show i'm
on netflix right now
speak across the planet i'm the first
chief criminal officer
in the world i'm a spokesperson for aarp
i lead a uh
i lead a truly blessed life that i
probably don't deserve but i'm grateful
to have and uh i i say it on every show
but i mean it too i work hard
to protect businesses and consumers from
the type of person that i used to be and
i take that [ __ ] very seriously
what are the triggers for you
the triggers are that pressure of not
being able to uh
of not being able to provide it's not an
ego trip anymore or anything else like
that i just want to be able that the
people that are around me
are taken care of and not having stress
or worry or anxiety i just want to be
able to pay my bills and make sure that
there's food on the table that the power
is running and not cut off
you know stuff like that so during the
pandemic that was one of the big things
i i you know
you're not speaking during the pandemic
all those consulting gigs are going to
end
so march when that began
i called the family in the kitchen my
two stepsons and my wife and i was like
hey the way this story ends
is with me back committing crime and in
prison for 20 years
and
because i voiced that i did i didn't
just tell them i told my fbi contacts i
told all the people that i worked with
and that was the first time in my life
that i had ever voiced that concern
before and when i did that everyone kind
of rounded up and kind of took me in
under the wing they would call me and
check on me the fbi about every two
weeks they'd call and say hey brett how
you doing let's have lunch
and it continued from there and
we got our mortgage delayed we got all
of our car payments delayed i had uh two
twenty thousand dollar loans from the
stimulus program that helped get us
through and everything else
credit went through the i mean credit
bottomed out completely but i didn't
break the law and uh found out i was a
lot stronger than i thought it was
and that's really beautiful to hear i
mean
the brutal thing is that it kind of
highlights the vicious cycle that people
who are potentially coming out of prison
or people who are
generally struggling to find work and
maybe coming from deprived or
um
like malign upbringings have in that
the thing that they need to be able to
get themselves going is the exact thing
that they can't find and the solution to
getting the thing that they can't get is
to do a thing which is going to further
ingrain them into a lifestyle which
pushes them more toward crime you know
what i've seen time and time again and i
i get a lot of people on my channel
and responses to interviews talking
about how criminals are sociopaths
i do not believe that i do not i believe
that most criminals are not sociopaths
they've just made very bad decisions
that have resulted in being convicted
and serving time in prison the people
that i served time with
99 of them just wanted to do their time
and they were very hopeful that they
would be able to get out and lead a
productive healthy life the problem is
is that i said it before
you're released from prison with the
exact same tools you go in with
unless you've got a support or safety
net outside of individuals that are
willing to help you
that can help you and unless you you
take the assistance that they're
offering
the chances of you recidivating i think
it's almost a hundred percent
number of people that you are
you have to people have to be willing to
help you you have to accept the help
that they're offering and and
it it takes that village you can't do it
yourself you cannot do it yourself you
have to have people helping you and
you've got to be and you know the people
that are out there they have to be
willing to help you too
do you think that there needs to be um
it almost sounds like when you're
talking about the fact that you've got
your uh fbi guy that checks in on you
every couple of weeks and that you can
have this conversation with the family
in the kitchen and stuff
i'm getting a vibes from it almost i'm
getting 12 step
really
you're right it actually sounds like
i've got a kind of like a sponsor i have
somebody that i can call if
the the
the credit card fraud gremlin appears or
whatever like in the back of my mind um
i'm wondering whether there needs to be
a more formalized version of this
whether there needs to be a
rehabilitation program for people who
are using
crime as a
method to help them get love or
recognition or status or identity in the
world um because it really does seem
like
you've cobbled together
not through design but simply by trial
and error a lot of error
a format that works for you where you
have a structure you have support you
understand the triggers you're able to
verbalize it you've got external
accountability you've got external
support you've got internal frameworks
that you can rely on
that i mean that to me seems like
something that potentially could be
scaled out to help
ex
criminals and and people that are coming
from a life of crime to perhaps try and
integrate themselves more effectively
actually i think you're right i do i
think that uh and i put some thought
into that but you know how i wouldn't
know how to go about doing that and what
i do is uh you know if someone gets out
of prison or someone needs help like
there's a gentleman on linkedin that i
talk about on my show today that i'm
releasing later today but uh he reached
out to me he's a computer science uh kid
and he's got some problems you know he's
he's thinking about because times are
hard he's thinking about going into
crime and i i gave the kid i was like
hey here's my phone number
give me a call we will talk about it
i'll listen to you i'll give you advice
whatsoever just keep your chin up it's
going to be all right
you know and i agree if you could come
up with a structure where you're able to
do that like an a.a type structure i
think it would be a great thing i think
it has to have that cognitive behavioral
therapy aspect to it
because there's a lot of cognitive
dissonance in the world but
i think you have to have that
and you've got to be you've got to be
that mentor you know i really
i really take it seriously if i see
somebody that that i think that is
really trying to turn things around you
know i sit down i'll talk to them as
much as they want to talk i'll listen
everything else and i'm adamant about
telling them hey
you're right now in this recovery mode
and recovery is never a straight line
you're going to backslide at some point
you're going to so understand that and
that doesn't mean you failed that just
means hey this happens as long as you're
moving forward at the end of the day
that's what matters you're going to get
there you know i think that uh there
there's so much
there's so much negativity
in the world you know
we look at we look at people who have
made these mistakes who have ended up in
prison and we judge them and we think
that they're not they're never going to
change but
we have to be willing to give them the
opportunity to change i think that's
what matters and hey i understand
budgets i understand our economy and i
understand we've got a whole shitload of
people out there that have never broken
the law and they deserve to have these
opportunities
too but i will tell you this
that person who's broken the law you're
going to pay for them one way or the
other you're either going to help them
rehabilitate and lead a healthy
productive life that helps people or
you're going to pay for their
incarceration time when they recidivate
again so where do you want to pay that
bill is what i would say and we have to
start understanding that or you know
things are just going to continue to
spiral and get worse
it's strange at the moment the
relationship i think the general public
has with
criminals in the criminal justice system
generally
it still feels even though it's
anybody that's read anything about this
topic knows that retributive justice
is kind of pointless you don't need to
take the uh free will doesn't exist
determinism red pill to
to get that
simply just look at the stats what are
you achieving
through that and yet i can
completely see that if you were the
subject of a home invasion or of a
stolen car or of a whatever there is a
sense of righteous venge vengeance that
kind of needs to be delivered and
this is the balance i mean
i've said it before on the show
it's it reminds me
slightly of the abortion debate that
both sides of the fence have incredibly
compelling arguments absolutely i
listened to a ben shapiro talk about
life conception at birth and such like
and i go bloody hell that seems that
seems pretty compelling and then i hear
someone who is pro-choice talking about
dangers to women's health and the
terrors of the foster care system and
all this stuff and i go well and
that there is no easy
answer to the position
that i get the same
energy from the discussion around
rehabilitation for uh criminals as well
yeah you know and i i agree with you
completely on the abortion thing i mean
both sides have extremely compelling
arguments and both sides
have a skewed philosophy that they try
to support as well
and you know i
i won't give my stance on that i think
it's just unfortunate that we can't
reach some sort of common middle ground
where both sides are somewhat upset
but
it's a satisfactory answer instead of
going to the extreme right or extreme
left of that equation well when you
optimize for an absolute you end up
having very strange externalities carl
newport told me about this to do with
email he said that he feels like almost
all of the problems that we have with
email would be fixed if every email cost
one pence or one cent to deliver i agree
the issue is when you drive the
approximate
cost of anything down to zero or when
you optimize for an absolute you end up
with these really bizarre externalities
because there's always going to be some
situations
that this doesn't apply to and whenever
you hear conversations talk about the
gun control right whenever you hear any
of these it turns from a
practical discussion
into a philosophical debate where you
use the reductio ad absurdum to try and
take this to the most extreme version of
whatever you can talk about and then you
go well
i i can't defend that position anymore
so
and it breaks down but i think generally
the conversation now is people are using
extreme views just like it's weapons
right they're picking up whatever the
most extreme point of view is and it
works as a
show of loyalty to your side and a
threat display to your opponent that's
what these positions for a lot of people
are it's like flying a flag of fealty
it's not to do with the specifics of the
position it's to do with the tribal
signaling both to your compatriots and
to your opponents and
yeah i mean
that's a
it's an unfortunate position and again
when you add in
the emotions that are brought out from
somebody that's potentially being the
victim of a crime of some kind whether
it be virtual or in real life
it's going to be difficult to get that
person to see
why they should
be the ones that
don't get the satisfaction of seeing
whatever righteous vengeance they feel
should be enacted i agree i agree i love
the way you detail that out truly
right it makes complete sense let's
bring this one home man i appreciate the
heck out of you i'm not surprised the
discovery channel and netflix and people
are picking you up i think you're an
amazing communicator your story is super
compelling thank you um sean atwood have
you been uh spoken to by him do you know
i have i i spoke to sean's uh co-host or
buddy that he that he pawns people off
on and i the show went really well so
the the producer was like we need you to
talk to sean
yeah he'll be great there's him and
there's another guy called james english
who's a scottish dude um so i'm gonna
send
i'm sure if
sean's already got you then i won't need
to but james is a james is a great guy
and he absolutely adores stories like
this man i i really hope all the best
for you in the future i think that the
story's super compelling i hope that the
discovery series goes it goes ahead well
and i'm going to be looking forward to
watching your netflix as well if people
want to get more of you
check out your show and all of that
where should they go sure so uh my show
is the brett johnson show on youtube
just
search for it on youtube i'm gonna pop
up i've got 35 episodes as of today and
we talk about cyber crime cyber security
stuff i may want to [ __ ] about you can
find me on linkedin as well just look
for brett johnson or google or anything
else like that i'm very easy to find let
me let me end with this chris and and
say that for people out there watching
to protect yourselves i need you to do
three things freeze your credit freeze
the credit of every single person in the
house it's free okay so freeze the
credit across across all three bureaus
monitor accounts place alerts on those
accounts and then finally use a password
manager do those things and you're going
to be okay you won't be as victimized as
97 of the population that's out there
all right i appreciate you
all right thanks again take care what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace